hey guys Pete here this will be my mr.
robot season 4 episode 6 recap and
review the episode was titled 406 not
acceptable it was written by Amelia gray
and of course directed by Sam S male in
episode 6 we have three stories playing
out in three different locations the
time is counting down to when Elliot's
shipping hack will go through and his
usefulness to the dark army will no
longer exist it all occurs in the
lead-up to the meeting of the dais group
that White Rose has arranged to replace
Phillip price as the CEO of ecore
overall it was a pretty good episode
even though it sets up roadblocks more
than it actually moves things along
Ellie it's part of the story outshines
the other two in a way that I just
wanted to get back to it but the Vera
and Darlene stories each end up
delivering something of value by the
episodes end beyond these we have a
short Minister gyeong scene and Leon's
returned to drop off the oxycontin
Elliot needs for his plan if you've been
following my mr. robot recaps you know I
have not been excited for Fernando Beres
return so I'll start with that part of
the story the biggest problem I have
with the brave traveler is that I don't
really care what he wants because it's
hard to figure out how it aligns with
the life-and-death situation that Elliot
finds himself in to this point it's felt
like bears return but only be an
obstacle that would slow Elliot down and
the pursuit of White Rose in the dark
army from what we know he wants to be
the king in New York and he wants Elliot
to be his architect since vera is the
man who killed Shayla there doesn't seem
to be an ending to the mr. robot series
that involves him getting what he wants
and having Elliot by his side in episode
6 he's kidnapped krysta who is Elliot's
former therapist because he thinks
she'll provide him with the information
he needs to get into Elliot's head while
I didn't enjoy watching his telling him
the little [ __ ] and the bully story I
guess it does add an extra dimension to
what he's trying to do he wants to break
Elliot down so he can be the one to
bring him back up and in that process
he'll own him it's an interesting
replacement for the idea of Vera just
trying to win them over based on their
spiritual connection or whatever is
going through beerus head but for me it
isn't enough to make me want to see more
of this care
character as far as I'm concerned what
turns out to make this work isn't what
we are a once or plans to do but what he
actually gets well we like Krista and
Elliot clearly cares about her we've
already seen more important characters
die this season in the last 24 hours as
far as the timeframes concerned her
captivity just doesn't feel that
consequential but she does have
information that no one else has she
knows about mr. robot and she tells Vera
this is the way to break Elliott what's
interesting about this is whatever birra
tries to do with this information it now
has the potential to provide us insight
into the third alter that mystery has
been on the back burner for several
episodes now and I can only hope that
Barret can help us get back to it if he
has to play a role in the rest of the
season
we know he has Elliott in the trunk of a
car and we know that the Deus group
meeting is going to be happening on this
same day I'm hoping this whole abduction
will bear fruit in the way of the
mystery about the altar rather than just
being something to hold Elliot up it
feels possible based on everything
that's going on that this could be the
thing that triggers Elliot to understand
what that third altar is the timeframe
of season 4 is pretty insane when you
think about the Alderson siblings we
catch up with Darlene at Angela's place
not too long after the events of episode
5
Angela's place works as a perfect
backdrop for the most visually
interesting thread of the story thanks
to her painting the walls black and
hanging photos everywhere with the faces
of the people covered up with colored
tape we get a nice conversation to start
things off where Elliot apologizes for
being an [ __ ] and that serves as a
reminder of how crazy the past couple of
days have been for these two take a
second and pause and think about what
has transpired since Christmas Eve and
remember that it's still Christmas Day
Darlene pauses when she sees Angela's
ballet shoes and then gets confronted by
Dom who has been sent by the dark army
in case you forgot Darlene seduced Dom
in season 3 in an effort to steal her
FBI credentials earlier in this season
we saw that Dom still has romantic
feelings for her despite holding her
responsible for ruining her life
Dom is now a dark army
furtive that has to do whatever they
tell her to in order to keep her family
safe
she holds Darlene responsible for that
after she locates Darlene Janus orders
down the killer since white rose is
essentially only looking for Eliot dongs
character is painfully restrained this
season because of the situation where
she was always one of the more dynamic
characters now she's trapped and we know
she cares about her family to the extent
that she wants to do whatever is
necessary to protect them at the same
time she is not a ruthless killer she's
capable she's cunning she's a great FBI
agent but she's not a hitman since
Darlene has rigged their phones to
locate each other that's all the dark
army needs if she won't give up Eliot's
location realizing she's expendable
Darlene tries to plead with Dom who does
a good job of explaining how she has no
choice but to do what they say in the
climax Dom holds your gun up and begs
Darlene to kill her it's surprising it's
a desperate move it's the only out she
can come up with that keeps her family
safe Darlene probably would never have
gone through with it but Janus enters
the room to learn that DOM can't follow
through with their orders as Janice
thinks over the situation and what to do
Darlene manages to wipe her phone in the
same way that Veera getting the
information about Eliot's disorder adds
a dimension to his part of the story Tom
and Darlene being held by the dark army
opens up their part of the story there's
a cliffhanger built in and there's
nothing about Janice's character that
tells me that she won't immediately
follow through with hurting Dom's family
and keep her word that this will be so
painful for her Veera has a plan to
inflict pain on Eliot and Janice is set
to do the same for Dom speaking of
Elliot his part of the story is all
about crossing lines in the short amount
of time that's passed since he first met
Olivia and made that human connection
with her a lot has happened he lost an
ally in tyrell pulled off an incredible
heist he's been chased by the cops and
he was hit by a car
still the decision he makes to
manipulate of Libya is as dark as we've
ever seen him go it's uncomfortable to
watch and rami malek really gets to show
off his acting chops here as he pushes
aside morality to get her to do what he
wants it's fascinating because we like
Eliot you can't watch the
Joe and not like Elliot right so here he
is crossing lines and doing the
unthinkable
he sets her up putting oxycontin in her
peppermint mocha and despite mr. robots
objections using everything at his
disposal to break her down to her credit
she tells him how things really are and
how everything he's done has caused
real-life consequences for so many
people he's come in contact with it's
not like Elliot isn't aware of these
things but it feels like he needs a
reminder at this point in the story
everything about their interaction seems
necessary and it makes for a gripping
episode of television much of the series
has hinged on Elliot not thinking
through the consequences of his action
in the beginning his intentions were
good he wanted to change the world for
the better but as the story nears the
end he's reduced to fighting for
survival it's a little bit harder to get
on board with what he's doing in that
scenario although it's not hard to
believe that these other choices that it
would make in this process he's
destroyed another life and what struck
me most about this part of the story was
that it didn't cross his mind that she
was going in the bathroom to kill
herself as viewers it felt obvious to us
we saw the razor blade we got the
explanation of it but it appears as if
it never crossed his mind or worse that
he didn't care either way in the lead up
and throughout this situation mr. robot
tries to be the voice of reason as they
leave her place mr. robot tries to make
sense of what's happened and what
they're up against going forward right
up until the moment beer as goons throw
Elliot in the trunk of their car and
drive away the episode ends there with
the clock still counting down until the
shipping cat goes through and Elliot is
of no more use to whiterose I don't know
about anyone else but I have to say that
Elliot not talking to us is starting to
wear on me at this point
mr. robots narration just doesn't do it
for me it serves its purpose and I'm
sure this is a creative decision where
they're trying to build up whenever he
does start to talk to us again but it
does feel like there's something missing
and while it does also give rami malek
the opportunity to shine as an actor
like there were some really good moments
here just before he decided to threaten
Olivia for example
as he listened to her tell him just how
bad of a person he actually is it does
actually
enhance
those situations but I need him to come
back to us please Elliot we need to hear
from you we need to hear what's going on
inside your head
Liane coming back feels important I
really don't see him only coming back
into the story in order to drop off some
drugs it was cool that they were at
Ron's and there was that callback to the
pilot episode but I think Leon is gonna
have to play an important role we have
to give some props to Janice she's a
great new character if we can't have her
ving back she's a pretty good
replacement her reaction when she walked
in on Dom and Darlene was pretty amazing
and she's just creepy
all the way through it's a little bit
unclear to me what Minister Jang is
actually doing here
we know that Elliot is essentially dead
once the shipping hack goes through
since there's got to be a Deadman switch
involved in the hack he has to keep
Elliot alive but it'll be curious to see
why he thinks that whatever he's going
to show him is going to change his mind
about wanting to fight back although
with Elliot and Vera's trunk there's a
lot of hurdles that have to be jumped
over before we're gonna get those two
together in a room so like I said I
think it's a pretty good episode
let's hope Vera is our key to the third
alter and Elliot figuring out what's
going on there I'm interested to find
out how Dom is gonna fight back she's
pretty much got her back against the
wall and her family is gonna pay the
price we have a dais group meeting right
around the corner even though they're
both captives currently Elliot and
Darlene were able to own the group's
bank accounts so I'm excited to see what
happens next
let me know in the comments what you
think how do you feel about Elliot's
dark turn how do you think he's gonna
get himself out of that Veera situation
how's Leo I'm gonna play a part in the
rest of the story please like this video
if you enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already sorry
about last week I had every intention of
making a video for episode 5 but it just
didn't work out as I was traveling and I
couldn't get it together thanks for
watching I will talk to you soon